here in an umbrella thorn tree in
Tanzania Africa some fissures lovebirds
are looking for a nice hollow in which
to nest and raise their young the love
bird is a small stout member of the
parrot family they're like humans in
that location is a very important factor
in finding a home and sometimes you find
just the right spot only to discover
somebody else got there first unlike
humans love birds who have found the
perfect tree Hollow can be evicted
merely because another bird like this
vanderdecken hornbill decides it might
want to take a look the hornbill of
pokes around a bit
but there's no prey here and this
wouldn't make a suitable hornbill home
so the resonant love bird moves back in
its getting to be the time for the love
bird to make love and to make eggs first
she feathers her nest with some nice
cushy frogs then she and her mate for
life pledged their union via kissing to
seal the deal the male passes edibles to
his beloved her love birds
it doesn't get any better than this now
actually it does get better than this
after foreplay the real play I mean they
are love birds don't you know